This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
So,
welcome back.
Let's continue the discussion on optical
geometry. So, before the break we've
seen that
the Gaussian curvature of the equatorial
plane of Schwarzschild in the optical
geometry is negative everywhere, right?
So, now we want to find out what this
actually means for the geodesics on the
surface. In other words, for our spatial
light rays.
Of course, to study the connection
between geodesics and curvature, you
look at the concept of geodesic
deviation, which I think you've seen
before, at least briefly. So, let's go
over this in the context of surfaces,
right?
So, geodesic deviation.
Um
Now, to do this, we look at
let's say
geodesics that have unit speed
in terms of our metric.
So, gamma
and remember we know in space, so I
write this parametrized as XA as a
function of the parameter.
We can now actually take T as the
parameter of our geodesics, right? In
the optical geometry we can take time.
Of course, that's the
we have of the
for the line element.
So, unit speed that means that G of
gamma dot gamma dot
is equal to one
with respect to our optical metric, I
should say G tilde.
Um and then of course they're geodesics,
so as always
we have that the covariant derivative of
the tangent vector in direction of the
tangent vector is zero.
And we want to we want to find out how
geodesics vary from each other. If you
if you go to neighboring geodesic, and
it's it's helpful to consider a vector
field that measures this deviation. And
so, one way of doing this is to
introduce a so-called connecting vector
field.
Vector field X.
And this connecting vector field, well,
first of all it commutes
with our
geodesics. It's really a congruence of
geodesics, I should say. All right, so
you have a
bunch of neighboring geodesics that
define a vector field like this.
And um
we measure the distance along X in such
a way that X is
orthogonal to the geodesic that we
consider. So, we also have this
orthogonality condition.
Right?
Okay.
Now,
if you have two commuting vectors
That's right, yeah.
Yes.
Yes. This is this is for the congruence.
And this is orthogonality along the
geodesic for which we look at the
deviation.
Yeah.
I'll draw a picture.
Anyway, let's look at the connecting
vector field
the commutator first.
If the commutator of two vector fields
vanishes, there's a particular property
for the covariant derivative, which I
think you've seen in one of your
tutorials. Oh, no, sorry, in the exam.
In the exam, okay.
Good.
Right? So, if you have
a vanishing
commutator, let's look at the
coordinates
at the components, rather, of this
vector.
Let's say the eighth component
is given by what? Well,
I'll write it like this.
Right?
It's the eighth component of the
commutator.
Now,
observe that we can now add
two terms to this which cancel.
Right?
So, why is this the same? Well, you can
observe that these terms with the gammas
are actually identical.
Because we can
relabel C and B, right? Since we repeat
indices, we can relabel them.
And then of course the the Levi-Civita
connection compatible with our optical
metric G tilde is symmetric in the lower
two indices. So, those two terms here
actually cancel
by relabeling
uh
and symmetry
of the of the gammas.
Right?
But now observe that what we have over
here is actually the component of a
covariant derivative.
Right? So, this is actually XB
gamma dot A
semicolon
B
minus same story here
gamma dot
B
X A semicolon B.
So, in other words, we really have the
eighth component of two covariant
derivatives, right? We have
um
the covariant derivative of the um
tangent vector field with respect to X
minus the covariant derivative of
X with respect to
gamma dot
the eighth component of that.
Right? So, the statement is really if
you have
commuting vector fields like this
this implies that the covariant
derivative of one with respect to the
other is equal to or the other way
round.
Like that.
That's a useful property.
Which we will use.
So, you've covered torque.
Okay.
So, now let's look at geodesic
deviation.
Let's plug in
oops.
Let's plug in our vector fields into the
the Riemann tensor.
Well, what is this according to the
definition
that um
I've been using.
Right? And then of course you get the
term
which
contains the commutator of X and
and gamma dot. But of course X and gamma
dot supposedly commute, so there's no
other contribution.
Right?
Uh what else can we see?
Well,
nabla gamma dot gamma dot is actually
zero because of the geodesic equation.
So, we're just left with this term.
And let's give this property a name,
let's call it star.
Then we can see that we can actually
rewrite this
in that way. We can switch X and gamma
dot in the covariant derivative here on
the right hand side. And that
expression is the covariant direct
derivative of the vector field along the
gamma dot. Sometimes this is written
then as uppercase DX
by D
T squared if that's
if that's our um
coordinate uh parameter.
Now, let's um
work this out in components because
remember we're on the surface. We've
seen an expression for
um the Riemann tensor in terms of the
Gaussian curvature. So, I'd like to find
out what's the connection of this this
uh
deviation vector with the Gaussian
curvature of the surface.
Right? So, now in components
Question? I would ask this real
notation, this is D over lambda or I
could think of it as D over D lambda.
Well, it's just the co- uh um
the covariant derivative with along the
curve, right? So,
so the eighth component of this is
uh what is it?
It's D
XA
by DT plus gamma
A
I write
I write it down later.
Let's just write down the the components
here first of all.
Right, so this will be R
A B C D
uh into into what? Into
uh gamma dot
D
X C
or rather B
gamma dot C.
Mhm. No, the C
D go with the both entries of the
Riemann Ah, C D, yes.
That's what I meant.
B
C D, yes.
Okay? Right.
Now, what is R A B C D? Remember
R A B C D
for the surface we define as Gaussian
curvature into G
A D G B C
minus G
A C G B D.
So, now pulling up one of the indices
So, a question, sorry.
Um
Well, this gives us delta A D
G B C minus pull up A gives us a delta A
C G B D.
So
Okay.
So, the A's component
then becomes what? K
delta A D
G B C minus delta A C G B D times
G dot B
X C
gamma dot D.
Yeah, sorry, it's a tedious
but that's what we get.
is K into
Okay, so we get a gamma dot A
times uh
times the contraction of
um
the tangent vector field and the
connecting vector field
minus
uh
X A times
B D uh huh
the contraction of
tangent vector field with itself
Right, so the length of the tangent
vector field like that.
Now, by assumption our connecting vector
field
um
is orthogonal to the geodesic um
that we that we start with.
To look at the deviation, this is zero.
And the tangent vector
to um the geodesic are of unit length,
that's one.
Right, so we're we're left with the
statement
that um
nabla gamma dot
gamma dot X
Well, yeah, A
is minus K
X A.
Right, or to say it differently
D squared X
by D T squared
is minus K X.
Yes? And
can you give me some some form of a
physical connection or some form of a
picture because I'm kind of
I'm not exactly sure what's
going on in my
physically like on the manifold the view
Well, so the physical picture is
just the same as before. We have a
surface, right? We have geodesics on the
surface. The surface is as a curvature.
We're now trying to find out what the
impact of the curvature is on the
geodesic. So, you take one geodesic, you
look at a neighboring geodesic and you
want to find out, well, does the
geodesic do do the geodesics diverge? Do
they converge? Are they parallel? This
will depend on the curvature.
And in what way? Well, exactly in the
way that we've seen. That's that's over
there, right?
And in the
X that you wrote, they are
Right. Should we think of them as
somehow a displacement or something?
Yeah, exactly, right? So, let's let's
draw a picture.
So, here's our geodesic.
Um we look at neighboring geodesics. So,
you know, you go to other points
they will have slightly different
geodesics, right? Like this. That's the
congruence of the geodesics.
We want to measure their deviation
um by considering this connecting vector
field X.
The connecting vector field is
orthogonal
to the geodesic like this. It commutes,
so you know, it closes. You can go
around this way or that way, doesn't
matter.
And um
Now, we've derived from the geodesic
deviation equation this statement. So,
you know, see how um
uh well, how the components of X, you
can take them to to to measure the the
deviation of neighboring geodesics
change as you move down um you know,
this geodesic gamma dot which is
parameterized by by T.
So, now you see
The left-hand side is the relative
acceleration That's right. as measured
in the parameters of the
connecting vector field. Right.
Yes.
Right.
So, now you can see that um the local
behavior of neighboring geodesics
actually depends on the um
the sign of the Gaussian curvature on
the surface. Of course, in
three-dimensional space it would be
different, but um if now the Gaussian
curvature
is positive
right?
You see that um
that geodesics locally converge.
And if the geodesic uh curvature is
negative, then of course they diverge.
If it's zero
well, you get um parallel geodesics.
So, now remember applying this to our
original problem of the optical geometry
for the equatorial plane of
Schwarzschild
um we always have a negative Gaussian
curvature as we've seen before the
break.
So, this means then
that uh and I also mentioned this at the
end of um of the last lecture briefly.
Now, we can actually see it. It really
means that the geodesics diverge locally
everywhere, right?
And the geodesics physically, remember,
are our light rays.
Right? So, the spatial light rays.
So, the geodesics or light rays
locally diverge everywhere.
I mean, if you if you like, we can um
look at the round metric again for the
sphere. Remember, K was equal to plus
one.
And if you're sitting on the equator, as
you know, the um
well, the geodesics would be great
circles, so it would be for example the
equator and the meridians, right? But as
you know, the meridians actually um
get closer together as you move away
from
um
from the equator, right? That's what
this says.
Yes.
This looks striking. You mean that you
have a harmonic oscillator It does,
doesn't it? Yeah.
That's exactly right. So, um
in some sense, if you you know, if
you're on the sphere
this is exactly what you get. K is equal
to one, you get a harmonic oscillator
equation in some sense. And this is how
the the meridians behave with respect to
each other.
Yeah.
How can you conclude from these
equations that they converge?
Well, just look at it. So
Okay,
so it's not for geodesics
only for X. Yeah, so you have to you
have to come up with some um notion of
how you measure the distance, right?
That's the X. I mean, you you would have
a a fixed
parameter value times the component of X
that measures the distance.
I mean, there's various ways of doing
it. It's No, so Right. X and X what? X
prime
in the neighborhood or something like
this. Mhm. And they diverge.
Right.
So, along the connecting vector field.
Okay.
So, now uh we see that light rays
locally diverge. Remember, we have our
our funny-shaped surface.
Um again, from looking at it, if you
know the Gaussian curvature is is is
obvious, but light rays always diverge.
Remember um one one minute. Remember
yesterday
uh
I've I've shown you pictures of actual
uh of actual gravitational lenses. We've
seen multiple images, right? Do you
remember this um
this Cheshire cat lens, right?
It sort of looks like this.
Okay, there's no nose.
I guess, but um actually it looked
rather strange. It was just like this.
Uh
Okay, forget that. Anyway, something
like this. Uh so, we had multiple images
of a background galaxy lensed by the
cluster. Now, of course, the cluster has
a complicated structure, right? It has
several galaxies, but this is far away
from the cluster. As far as these um
light rays are concerned uh it's not
entirely right to say this, but you
know, basically this is a Schwarzschild
system.
Um far away from any mass distribution
sufficiently far away, if it's a compact
mass distribution, so this looks like a
like a point mass.
Um out there, space is basically
um Schwarzschild.
Right? So, um
But we actually see multiple images. But
if the light rays converge locally uh
sorry, diverge locally everywhere, how
is it possible that they start at the
light source do something and then come
back together
at the observer in such a way that you
see multiple images?
So, the answer clearly can't be that
it's a local property, so it must be a
global property. In other words,
topology comes in. So, let's try to
understand this. And of course, to
connect curvature and and the topology
of a surface, you have to look at
Gauss-Bonnet, which you may or may not
know.
So, let's um
look at this.
Sorry, let me let me finish by
writing this down as a question.
So, if light rays diverge locally, um
how can multiple images be formed?
Can you make a brief historical remark
on whether this confused people?
Because intuitively you would say, well,
if you press it down to space, you would
assume it's a
space with a positive curvature.
Um You have the local convergence if you
want to understand lensing.
Well, um I see.
Um
I was certainly very surprised when I
saw it first.
Um
and I think people haven't thought about
this um
in these terms before.
So, um for lensing, the first paper to
do it um is actually Gibbons and Werner,
2008.
Nobody looked at it before? Not like
this, no.
Uh and the reason is in in astronomy, um
people don't really look at it from the
GR point of view. They basically start
with a Euclidean space, which space, you
know, the universe basically is a
spatially flat, um as far as we can
tell, and um
any any lenses are very much localized.
So, you don't need all this all this
machinery. You can actually do a lot of
lensing with without that. And I'll come
to this at the very end. I'll show you
um hopefully how how it's set up in
astrophysics, and that's really what
people have used for a long time. But to
discuss lensing in a sort of more GR
setting in this way, anyway, I think
hasn't been done before.
Um
now of course, the natural arena for
lensing is um null geodesics. That's
again more complicated. So, Capozziello,
for example, did a lot of work on
Fermat's principle in Lorentzian um
spacetimes. But this is kind of in
between. It's general relativistic, but
it's the spatial picture,
uh but it's more geometrical compared to
what the astronomers used to in the
standard formalism.
Anyway.
So, back to our question. If light rays
diverge locally, how can multiple images
be formed? Well, the answer then is
really um
it's it's a global property.
Um so, lensing
is intrinsically global.
I mean, it sounds rather wishy-washy I
suppose it is if I say it like that. Um
but I will actually show you that the
topological contribution for
Schwarzschild is essential really
essential for multiple images to occur.
Um I can show this explicitly. So,
so therefore, use Gauss-Bonnet.
Okay.
No.
Okay, Gauss-Bonnet.
So, that's the last topic
um
of these lectures um except that at the
end I'll I'll show a little bit
I'll show you a little bit about um
the framework in astrophysics as well.
Okay, Gauss-Bonnet. So, we consider the
optical geometry of a static spherically
symmetric spacetime, not necessarily in
vacuum. Of course, if it's in vacuum, by
Birkhoff's theorem,
it will be Schwarzschild, right? So,
we've seen some of this already, but uh
it doesn't have to be in vacuum. It can
be slightly more general. So, consider
the optical geometry
of a static
spherically symmetric spacetime,
um
not necessarily in vacuum.
So, if it's vacuum, it's Schwarzschild.
If it's not vacuum, um you can consider,
you know, a fluid that has these
properties,
and then the field equations take on a
special form, which is called the
Tolman-Oppenheimer-Volkoff.
You can solve it, right?
Um that's in his paper if you're
interested.
Um of course, we will just use
Schwarzschild for the purpose of these
lectures anyway.
But it's a bit more general.
Um
so, if the optical metric
Oops.
g twiddle,
and because of um
spherically spherically symmetry, we can
we can restrict our attention just to um
the geodesically complete surface of the
equatorial plane or any other other
plane to the through the origin.
So,
again, with all loss of generality,
choose
the equatorial plane in the same these
standard uh spherical coordinates.
Right? So, we have a
we have this uh equatorial plane in the
optical geometry g twiddle, and within
this, let's consider some
uh
some some region, some surface region,
region A,
which can have a boundary, and the
boundary may be uh piecewise straight uh
piecewise smooth.
Um with dA.
So, it consists of uh smooth bits,
right? Smooth curves and vertices.
So,
uh I mean, it's
it's a bit symbolic to write like this,
but let's say consists of curves
in the union with
uh the vertices.
So, with
smooth boundary curves,
C,
so again, we parameterize them somehow,
T say.
Um let's take the components to be
corresponding to unit speed boundary
curves.
Right? So, unit speed.
Um so, g twiddle
of c.c
is equal to 1.
Um
then the vertices,
V,
so at the at the vertices, your your
smooth boundary curve undergoes a jump,
right? That That's right, the tangent
vectors undergo a jump.
And this jump is called jump angle. And
of course, you can measure the jump
angle inside or outside.
Um if you want to define the exterior
jump angle.
Right? So, vertices
with exterior jump angles
epsilon.
Um I'll draw a picture later.
So, what other properties do we have
with a surface? The surface might have
holes. The number of holes of um
a topological disk can be described by
what's called the Euler characteristic,
which you might be familiar with. So,
there's also
an Euler characteristic,
chi,
which is uh in the case of a disk, it's
1 - g, where g is the number of holes
that your surface has.
The surface um might have a curvature,
as we've seen before. So, we would have
a Gaussian curvature.
Again, we call this uppercase K.
And there's also a a quantity which you
may or may not have seen before. It's
called the geodesic curvature.
So, it's the geodesic curvature, which
is defined because only on the smooth
parts of the boundary curve.
It's denoted by little kappa, and I'm
afraid
it just looks like a small version of
the big K, but
it's conventional.
Oh, actually oh, maybe I can
shall I write like this?
Okay.
Kappa.
So, that's um the length of
the vector of the covariant derivative
of the boundary curve along the tangent
vectors, like this.
Right? So, you can see immediately from
the definition
um that the geodesic curvature of a
geodesic is zero. So, it's a quantity
that measures to what extent
a curve
um is not a geodesic.
Or is the acceleration? It is the
acceleration. Yes.
Right?
So, given all this stuff I'm sorry and
and these things of course um they're
metric quantities with respect to
our optical metric G tilde.
The angles are two.
So, uh given all this
Yes.
What is the meaning behind this
Chinese letters?
So, sorry repeat the question, please.
Could you project the meaning in some
some easy words what is written there
what what all this what this is all
about?
Uh yeah yeah yeah. Um okay.
Okay, let me let me draw a picture.
So, this is So, it's a the blackboard
represents the um
the equatorial plane in the uh optical
metric
and we have some
bounded region A
uh
which has a boundary DA
which consists of smooth as piecewise
smooth it consists of smooth bits which
is this and that, right? That's part of
C. But it also has vertices
like over here.
Like V1, V2, whatever.
Um
You have a well-defined um tangent
vector of course everywhere except at
the vertices. But um
So, here is tangent vector
from from Okay, let's call it C1 and C2,
right? So, DA
is C1 with C2 and V1 and V2.
Maybe in a particular order, anyway. See
what I mean? Um So, this is the tangent
vector of C1 at V2. Now, as you As you
move around in this orientation, you
need a consistent orientation as well.
Um
The next tangent vector
um on C2 at at this particular vertex,
of course, we start like this, right?
So, you have a a jump angle.
Which um
is the jump angle corresponding to this
vertex. Let's call it epsilon two.
Similar thing here. You have a
tangent vector from C2 at V1. You'll
have a tangent vector
um
on C1 at V1. It starts like this. So,
there's another jump in the tangent
vector. That's the exterior jump angle
epsilon one.
Um yeah, what else is going on? So, we
have a um Gaussian curvature of the
surface
um
in A, right? We have a geodesic
curvature kappa
defined in this particular way along the
the smooth part of the boundary. We
might also have a holes.
So, so there might be a hole in it.
Right? G.
And of course, if we have a hole, we
need a boundary curve for the hole. So,
this then is also some some boundary
curve
C of of the hole.
Do you see what I mean with here? We
only measure holes of the dimension of
A not much on the hole.
That's right. Yes. So, this is
topologically that's a disc. Yeah.
Okay. And this goes into the boundary as
well.
The extra C
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's part of the
boundary. That's right. Yes. So, but
what is the um the Gaussian curvature if
we have a just the equatorial plane?
Yeah, but remember this this can be
curved, right? So, So, this is a
This is part of a region on our surface.
So, maybe like like this.
Right? So, it lives on the surface in
the embedding.
It has a curvature.
Which varies from Which varies might It
might possibly vary from point to
Any other questions?
I mean I show you a set up of this and
then of course we do calculations. Yes.
How are are these jump angles defined by
just by use of the metric or Exactly.
Yes. All of So, all metric quantities
here like the Gaussian curvature and so
on, geodesic curvature and of course
angles too, they're all measured with
respect to to uh G tilde. Yes.
That's the only metric we have here.
Anything else?
Well, you see how I use it in in a
moment, but let let me um write down the
statement
the Gauss-Bonnet theorem.
So, it's a it's a beautiful theorem
um which connects local properties of
the surface, the Gaussian curvature,
with the global properties So, in
particular with um
with the Euler characteristic, the
number of holes. But of course, we have
to take care of the boundary as well.
So, the statement is that
the integral
of K
over A
plus
the integral along the boundary
Well, um
really the the smooth part of the
boundary
right? Of the geodesic curvature
plus Well, from the jump angles we get
also contributions.
The sum over the exterior um jump angles
of the vertices, all of this stuff is
equal to 2 pi
chi
of A. Yes. So, you're assuming that uh
V is a finite set.
Yeah.
Yes.
We just have a finite number of
vertices.
Otherwise, it's it's smooth. So, it's
piecewise smooth.
Okay?
So, how can we apply this to our lensing
problem? Well, I want to look at two
constructions. The first construction
will show us how the topology really um
you know, impinges on the number of lens
images we can see.
And then the second construction will be
to actually compute the deflection
angle, finally, the thing that I've
been, you know, rambling on about for
the last two lectures. Uh we can
actually derive it from this um from
this point of view, which is very
different from what you might have seen
in the textbooks. They always do it the
same way, you know, work out the
deflection angle, but here you see a
different
way to do it. Okay, so A
So, let's call this
topology
and multiple images.
Images in the sense of lens image.
Okay?
So, I can basically have the same setup
as I've as I've drawn it
uh over there. So, let's suppose we have
a light source S
and an observer O, right?
Now, if we have multiple images, let's
say we have two images.
That means
there are two light rays connecting S
and O, right? Like this, let's say.
So, these are now light rays, let's say
I don't know, gamma one
gamma two.
Right? So, we have a light source
S
observer
O
As you can see, these correspond to our
vertices.
Um
light rays
gamma one, gamma two.
Um
Really a particular orientation.
Actually, the light rays go like this.
We have
be careful in applying a consistent
orientation though for Gauss-Bonnet.
Uh
Well, and then there might be holes. So,
remember for example, for Schwarzschild,
we have um we actually have a hole.
Um
So, we have to we have to use an inner
boundary curve for this hole.
And um it's actually convenient to take
the radius of the photon orbit to be the
inner boundary curve.
And the reason for doing is that it's a
geodesic, right? So, this actually makes
computing the geodesic curvature in this
case very easy. We'll see this in a
moment. Right? So, there might be Let's
call this gamma P.
So, the inner boundary
gamma P, e.g. for Schwarzschild
Take the circular photon orbit
at uh
R is equal to 3M as you've seen before.
So, in some sense, I have the feeling of
this picture is looking into the throat
from up. That's right.
That's right. Yes. So, So, the Z
coordinate that we've seen before for
the you know, for the embedding so comes
out of the blackboard now.
Um and this is now um
the surface region A that encloses the
throat.
And well, we want to determine whether
this kind of setup is actually possible,
right? Can we have multiple images like
this?
So, then remember that at these jump
angles here, this is um
Let's call this epsilon S for the
source. There's a jump angle here
epsilon O.
And well, this setup is only possible of
course if um
Well, if these two light rays converge
at S and O as drawn, right? So, in other
words, if those angles here
are really positive.
So, let's call them I don't know
theta S
theta O
Right?
So
This is like the inner jump angle. Of
course, it's related to the outer jump
angle just by
subtracting them from pi.
And the question is
can such a situation arise?
Right? Is this possible?
I mean, is it possible to have the two
light rays reconverging of the at the
observer? Is possible to have
multiple I E two images in this case?
Well, let's check.
So, it's possible
if these two angles theta S and theta O
are really positive.
Now, clearly this is 2 pi
minus
epsilon S epsilon O, right? So, it's 2
pi minus the sum over the
exterior jump angles of
at the vertices.
So, according to Gauss-Bonnet
this is
is what?
So, you see we
we subtract this.
So, it's 2 pi times 1 minus chi. So,
it's 2 pi that's actually pi and yet
another pi. So, it's pi minus E S minus
minus
plus pi minus E zero. Logically
speaking, it's not one full angle. It's
two half angles because of this picture.
Ah, sorry. Say say say
I agree. It's 2 pi, but it's individual
pies. Yes, yes. Of course. One epsilon
and the other one is zero. Of course,
yeah.
Um it's very suggestive of setting up a
Let's just look at this setup. Of
course, you can do it in other ways. Um
Um
plus
where the integral over the smooth
boundary curve C of the geodesic
curvature times DT. Um well, plus the
integral of the Gaussian curvature.
Right? Um
Now, this is 2 pi times the number of
holes in principle. Right? Let's say we
have multiple
Schwarzschild black holes in there.
Could be.
2 pi G
Um
plus
the rest.
Well, but what is C?
Um
Well, the way we set this up is it's
gamma one
and gamma two. I mean, if if you want to
be
Um
Once you correctly really have to um
be consistent as far as the orientation
is concerned, so we really have to
reverse gamma two, but doesn't really
make a great deal of difference.
Plus um this gamma P
Right? So, if
if it reverse the orientation
then
we have to have a consistent
orientation. It's actually like this
on the inner boundary curve gamma P.
Uh well, what is kappa evaluated on on
the smooth boundary bits?
Well, gamma one is a light ray. It's a
geodesic. Gamma two is a light ray. It's
a geodesic. Gamma P we've chosen to be
the radius of the photon orbit. That's a
geodesic tool. So
kappa of the smooth part of the boundary
is zero conveniently.
Right?
So, we end up
with the statement that
for this multiple imaging situation to
occur
um
2 pi G plus the integral of the Gaussian
curvature over the uh the surface region
must be greater than zero.
But remember, for Schwarzschild
Well, that's of course the sort of model
that we have in the
back of our minds. For Schwarzschild,
kappa is always negative.
So, for this to be true
we must have
um
the property that G is certainly greater
than zero. It's at least one. So, it's
an integer.
Right?
Or one in the case of just one
Schwarzschild black hole.
Right?
But that's the topological contribution.
So, you see multiple images in the case
of a Schwarzschild um
solution that the two images that we get
here is actually only possible if the
topology is non-singular. So, you can
really conclude in this particular case
that um the topological contribution is
essential for multiple images to occur.
Right? So, hence
this case
is really essential
for multiple lens images um
to occur.
And conversely, the topology of the
throat was forced upon us because the
three-dimensional metric cannot be put
on a space that doesn't have a hole.
Is that right? Uh I think that's right.
That's right. What if there is a massive
body uh which radius is just a radius of
the throat and it's not a black hole?
Yeah, okay. I'll come to this. So, um
in this particular case where we have
Schwarzschild in mind, here we really
see that it's essential if um there's a
massive body. If we don't have a um
I mean, if we don't have a photon orbit,
we don't have a a horizon
then uh the situation will will change.
Then kappa can actually be positive. So,
typically for a galaxy, you know,
um
a mass distribution
that's um
static spherically symmetric but not
Schwarzschild, um you don't get this
kind of picture in the embedding
diagram.
Whereas clearly uh where the Gaussian
curvature is is clearly negative
everywhere, um something simpler
happens. It just sort of bulges out like
that.
But here you can see the Gaussian
curvature is actually positive.
Right? So, so in this case, the sign of
K can actually change. And in that case,
of course, you can also have other
images because of that, right? So, of
course, it's more complicated in the
general case, but in the particular case
of Schwarzschild, we see that topology
is really essential. In the more general
case, it's not essential, but it comes
in.
Right? So, so the topological
contribution is really important. That's
certainly true to say um for lensing in
general even.
So
And this is what I meant earlier. Um
that's the precise meaning of what I
meant earlier by the statement that
lensing is really intrinsically a global
effect. So, we have to take the the
topology of the surface into account. Um
in the case like Schwarzschild, it's
actually essential. It doesn't work
without.
In the more general case, well, it
contributes, but K can also be positive,
right? So, it's less strict. Yes. Is
there a
Is there an intuitive explanation for
this
Gauss-Bonnet
theorem?
Ah. It's a
logical effect, right? It It arises from
this theorem. Yes. It's really
Yeah.
Okay.
It's It's a It's a beautiful theorem.
It's not easy to derive. I couldn't
just, you know, cough up a derivation of
this immediately. Um so, this is for a
surface with boundary. Let me just
motivate for you um a particular case.
So, suppose your two-dimensional surface
actually has no boundary.
Right? So, for example
consider the surface to be
our old friend S2 again.
So, then
there's nothing like this. We just don't
have a boundary. And Gauss-Bonnet then
says, well, the integral of the Gaussian
curvature over the surface must be
um
uh 2 pi times the Euler characteristic.
Right? Now, remember we've already
worked out uh K for S2
K for S2 is equal to one.
The integral
over the over the unit radius sphere
is 4 pi.
Right? So, we get the statement 1 times
4 pi is equal to 2 pi times Well, what's
the Euler characteristic of of a sphere?
Well, it is indeed two.
Um
So, you can sort of see that it works in
this case.
Why is it two when we have
uh non-this
definition with one
This is for a topological disk.
Um where we have a boundary curve. If
you don't have a boundary curve, it's
actually 2 minus 2 G.
Right? And in this case, of course, the
sphere has no hole in it, so you get
two. That's different, right? This is
for a disk with boundary. This is for a
surface without boundary.
But the beautiful thing is if you deform
the sphere
topologically
Mhm. it stays the same.
That's right. So, so if if it if it's
Right? If it doesn't If you don't
introduce a boundary surface, that's
also a topological sphere
um
with the same Euler characteristic.
Okay. So, here now we've seen the other
here.
I know. Hold on. Hold on.
So, this is only for topological disk
where you have a boundary.
Um like this
relates to the other question. In this
case, if there's no boundary,
um,
chi is actually 2 - 2 * number of holes.
So, for the for topological sphere,
there's no hole, g is equal to zero.
It's a different formula.
Right? Um, yes. What is the definition
of boundary because I think that the
boundary of the S2 is maybe the S2
itself because um, if you take a point
out of the S2, there's always if you lay
them all around it, you have part of the
S2 and then part of the
not the S2.
Uh, well, I mean this is really in the
standard sense of um, surface, you know,
manifold without boundary. Um,
you don't have a boundary curve that
that um, you know, bounds S2, of course.
That's that's what we what we need.
Right? You can have um, two two
geodesics that um, stay long way away
from the
um, from the throat, but you still have
them diverging and converging. I mean,
what we said earlier is just a local
property of the of the geodesics.
Right? It's just local.
So, but actually Frederick I mean, he's
quite right. You can have um,
more complicated lensing. This is all
relativistic, remember? You can actually
You could consider in principle the
case, I haven't done it here, that you
have um, you know, geodesics wrapping
around
and and actually rotating several times
and then move back out again. It's It's
possible.
Um,
I've considered the sort of trivial case
because that's actually what's going on
in nature. That's actually what we
observe in lensing, right? So, these
light rays pass by the lens, the galaxy
in distance of, you know, thousands of
of parsecs typically.
So, it's actually rather trivial.
So, I want to show you the trivial
example because even in the trivial
example, the topological contribution
comes in.
Um, this, yes, we could also discuss,
but it just makes things more
complicated and it's never been
observed, I think. Um,
Anyway, so let me What's the What's the
one more question?
Yes. You mentioned it has never been
observed. Like how would you distinguish
Ah, yeah, very good question. Um,
you could um,
So, if you work out the lensing
properties of of these multiple orbits,
they just come out, of course, in you
know, in different point.
Um,
actually to you know, for the lensing to
occur, you have to make sure not just
that these
geodesics get deflected at the at the
um, black hole, but they have to start
at some emission event and you actually
have to be able to observe them. So,
there's an additional
just geometrically um,
constraint that these geodesics really
end up where they where they should so
that we can observe them and then this
lensing case would be slightly
different. You could I think take, you
know, tell it apart. Um,
But anyway, let me let me now go on from
um,
the first part to the second part. Let's
let's use Gauss-Bonnet to um,
to um, actually work out the deflection
angle in this simple case, in the sort
of trivial case where the light ray
passes by the black hole at um, at great
distance. Now, what's the the deflection
angle that I've written down yesterday,
right?
So, there's no B.
And for this uh, computation, we again
use Gauss-Bonnet,
but um,
with a different region,
which turns out to be useful. So, again,
we have our light source,
which sends out light.
There's a lens somewhere.
The lens might have uh, you know, a
photon sphere. We're actually way away
from the photons. We We don't really
care, but there will be some, you know,
small deflection.
And then we end up at the observer here.
Now, let's suppose we take our
as this would have been the undeflected
ray.
Um,
it passes by the the the lens at some
distance. Well, let's say let's just
take the coordinate distance because
it's such a long way away from the black
hole, we can use Schwarzschild
coordinates. That's the impact parameter
B.
And um,
the region I want to consider is the
following. It It has the following
boundary. It has the light ray gamma
and it has something which is not a
light ray, just um,
um, an arc
that connects O
back with S.
Like this.
And um,
that's the boundary curve C.
Let's make it symmetric. We want to work
out the asymptotic deflection angle. So,
we eventually we want to let S go off to
infinity in one direction, O go off to
infinity in the other direction.
Um,
so let's just make to make life easy for
ourselves, let's say the distance from S
to L
is the same as the distance from L to O,
which we call big R.
And um,
the boundary curve C
is just this arc uh,
X A of T.
Um,
well,
let's just write it in in polar
coordinates. R of T is big R, it's
constant.
And phi
So, asymptotically, let's say this is
also the the polar axis for our phi
coordinate system,
uh, phi then goes from
let's call this angle
alpha,
goes from minus alpha to pi.
Okay, and then this alpha will actually
become our asymptotic deflection angle
of the light rays. As this you can sort
of see.
And um, okay, so gamma is the light ray.
And the region that we want to apply
Gauss-Bonnet to is now this.
It depends, of course, on on R. It's
bigger.
Eventually, we let um,
we let R go to infinity.
But actually for for this to work,
really what we what we need to have is
that the Schwarzschild radius, so
that's, you know, 2M,
must be a lot smaller than the impact
parameter, which itself is a lot smaller
than R.
And then it works.
But in the limit, it's exact.
The statement.
So, it's a picture in this curved
two-dimensional space, but this whole
picture spans over a huge range
Mhm.
such that far outside it looks like
approximately Euclidean space. Exactly.
So, as as R goes to infinity,
um,
dt squared, that's actually going to be
important, goes to its Okay,
bad notation here. But dr squared plus r
squared d phi squared, in other words,
uh,
the Euclidean metric of of the surface,
right? Uh,
Riemannian surface, but in polar
coordinates.
Okay.
Now, we also ignore cosmology in this
setup, right? Of course, physically we
we have the lens which is somewhere in
the universe, the universe expands. So,
it's really conformally Euclidean, but
it's not not a big problem. We can
actually change this. But um, if you
want to be pedantic, you can say, "Okay,
this R um,
is is very large, but it's actually less
large than the Hubble parameter."
Right? Then we have to take into account
cosmology, but
let's leave it at that for the time
being.
Can be changed easily. So, what about
AR? Let's apply Gauss-Bonnet
to this. First of all,
in this case, there's now no hole,
right? AR is topologically trivial, it's
topologically uh, a disk without hole,
so chi is equal to one.
That's for sure.
Um,
right? So, let me write down
Gauss-Bonnet again.
So, we just get 2 pi here.
Um,
what about the Gaussian
cur- where the geodesic curvature on the
boundary curve?
Um,
let me work it out over here. Thanks.
So, the geodesic curvature of the light
ray, of course, is zero because that's
geodesic.
What's the geodesic curvature on our
boundary curve?
So, we have to work out now the geodesic
curvature of um, a circular arc in
well, essentially in um,
in flat Euclidean geometry.
By the way, what are the um,
non-vanishing connection components
here?
So, dt squared
is dr squared plus r squared d phi
squared.
Let's say um,
what are the non-vanishing connection
components?
Well, we've already worked this out
earlier. I mean, in the last lecture
because this is again of our special
form,
right? So,
it would be gamma r phi phi
and gamma Oops.
What's the other one?
Phi r phi, I think.
So, so you know, our function f of r is
simply r. Remember, this was um,
minus f f prime, so this is just minus
r. And this was f prime over f, so
that's 1 over r.
So, what's um,
I mean, it's actually trivial if you
know Gauss if if you know the geodesic
curvature, it's just the geodesic
curvature of a circle in Euclidean
space, but let's work it out the long
way uh for fun. So, what is kappa of C?
So, by definition, it's the length with
respect to the optical metric when the
in the Euclidean domain relative to
Euclidean metric here
of
nabla C. C.
Right?
Okay.
So, let's look at the components. What
is
the eighth component of this?
Well, it will be C. B C. A semicolon B,
right? So, C. B C. A, B plus gamma A B C
C.
C C. B.
And what is C. B? Well, we have polar
coordinates, so
So, what is it? Um
C. It's It's certainly by by by
by um circle symmetry, it can only have
a component in the phi direction.
Uh there's no radial component of the
tangent vector.
Um
Let me write down the curve again. So, C
is um is really given by R of phi is R
is constant.
So, what is C. uh phi? Now, remember for
Gauss-Bonnet,
it was for this definition, we have unit
speed curves.
So, the unit speed condition fixes our
um component here.
Right? So, G
C. C is 1
means then that Well, there's only a phi
component that G phi phi C. phi C. phi
is equal to 1.
Uh G phi phi is R squared evaluated at
the curve is big R. So, we conclude then
that C. phi is simply
Well, it's simply 1 over big R, right?
Now, in case it's a constant component,
so whatever it is um in the covariant
derivative, the derivatives will vanish.
So, we're only left with terms from the
connection components.
Um
So, you can see we have a contraction
here with the components
gamma. C. Well, we only have one
component in the phi direction. So, you
see the only component of the covariant
derivative um is actually the the radial
component.
Right? So, the only non-vanishing
component of the covariant derivative is
the R component,
which will be given by gamma phi
Uh sorry, gamma R phi phi C. phi
squared.
And um
Well, and gamma R phi phi is minus R
evaluated at the curve is minus big R
divided by R squared, so it's minus 1
over R.
So, the geodesic curvature Well,
we can work it out over here. It's the
length. Well, it's just one component,
so it's um
Well, it's
and it's Riemannian, so it's G R R
C. R C. R
to the power of a half.
So, it's basically this squared square
rooted,
so it's 1 over R.
So, you get the result is probably
perfectly obvious anyway. The Gauss sum
curvature and sorry, the geodesic
curvature of a circle in Euclidean space
is 1 over the radius of that circle. And
clearly, you can see now if you let the
radius of a circle go to infinity,
you get a straight line. A straight line
is a geodesic in Euclidean space. Well,
yes, indeed, kappa is equal to zero as
you would expect.
Right? So, it makes perfect sense.
Now, um
let's go back to our computation here
then.
So, as R goes to infinity, as we move
the circle out into to the Euclidean
domain that we've been using over there,
uh what happens? Well,
we get the domain, let's call it A
infinity.
K D A
plus
um
Well,
what is DT?
You see at at R is equal to constant.
Well, if
Right over here.
Um
If R is constant, DT squared is DR
squared plus R squared D phi squared,
right? So, DT
is just R D phi.
Right? So,
integrating
over this bit then is the integral of
of kappa of C. which we've shown to be 1
over R times DT, but that's really R D
phi over the range of C. The C C goes
from minus alpha to pi.
Plus the jump angles. Well,
by symmetry, we have a circular um
We have a circular arc intersecting
essentially radial arcs. They're offset,
but as you go to infinity, um
they become orthogonal. So, the two jump
angles are actually just pi by 2 pi by 2
in the limit. Right? It's 2 times pi by
is equal to 2 pi.
This
gives us
pi plus alpha.
That's obviously pi.
Well, what about the jump angle at where
the light ray
Yeah, so so these jump angles turn to pi
by 2 as R goes to infinity.
The other one, too. Yes, but what about
the one in the middle where
There's no jump angle. I'm sorry?
There is There is no jump angle. It's a
It's a smooth It's a light ray. It's
just, you know, curved. Oh, it's smooth.
Yes.
There's no jump There's only two
vertices, S and O, just like before.
Right?
Um I mean, essentially, it looks as if
there was a jump angle, and that's what
the astronomers do. In the standard
formalism, you actually treat the light
rays as straight lines in Euclidean
space, and there's a is a is actually a
kink. There's a jump angle there.
But here, we're doing it in this sort of
GR setting, we don't. We just take it as
it is. It's a smooth
light ray.
Right?
Okay. So, that's what we get here. The
the jump angles that do occur are at the
two vertices, S and O, where we
actually, you know, we we match two
different curves.
And um well, as you can see, we can
rearrange.
Sorry about the
um
layout of the of the blackboards,
but now we can we can um deduce.
Yes?
So, you are
alpha approaches infinity, alpha goes to
zero, and we are moving a path from
observer towards infinity. Yeah.
That's right.
And then the region I I'll just call A
infinity. So, it's the region that is
bounded by this infinite light ray,
excludes the lens, and goes all the way
off to infinity.
And this um
deflection angle is then minus
the integral of the Gaussian curvature
over this region A infinity
integrated, you know,
So, it's all of this
A infinity excluding the lens,
and then going off to infinity.
That's the statement. And you've seen we
haven't actually made any approximation.
That's Excuse me, that equation is exact
for the deflection angle in the case of
um a static spherically symmetric lens.
And um if you think about it, it's a
very surprising equation, I think.
So, note.
Um
Well, normally, when you say, "Okay, a
mass deflects light,"
you would think that the action of
deflection
of course depends on the mass that's
enclosed within the impact parameter.
Right? You have a light ray. The light
ray is deflected by some stuff, by some
mass. The more mass you have inside of
the of
deflection angle
is indeed proportional to to M as we've
seen yesterday. That's what we want to
work out later in a moment. Right?
But actually, look at this equation.
It tells you you can look the other way.
You can work out a quantity integrated
from the light ray off to infinity
excluding the lens.
Right? You're not looking at what's
enclosed in the impact parameter, you
look at what's outside of it.
So, how how can it be possible that you
get the same thing? Again, it tells you
it's a global effect. Lensing is a
global effect. You can look on the
inside, or you can also choose to look
at the outside. Get the same thing. Uh
yeah, sorry, there was a question.
Oh, yes.
Very good.
Very good. Yes. Huh. Okay.
Let me make this this note first. Okay.
So,
So, the deflection angle alpha um
is determined
by some quantity, you know, the integral
of the Gaussian curvature of the optical
metric, blah blah blah,
outside of the light ray.
So, okay. Obviously, that's true, and it
just underscores again that lensing is
intrinsically global.
Right?
We have seen a topological property.
That's in some sense saying the same
thing.
Um
Yes, and then as you have observed, um
Now, to actually compute this, how do we
compute this? Well, as you can see the
region already contains the answer. It
contains the actual light ray.
Right? Is that a problem? Well, not
really. It just means you have to
compute this iteratively.
You might say, "Okay, um we don't know
what the deflection is. Let's say
initially
we take the boundary to be an
undeflected light ray, then you get some
value for the deflection angle
proportional to M." Okay, so this then
gives you a slightly better fit for the
actual light ray. Now we have a better
boundary.
It's still not the the the precise light
ray. You plug it in again and get, you
know, third order corrections and so on.
So, um
this formula contains
the answer, so you have to solve it
iteratively.
And that's exactly what we're going to
do now.
Um
Yes?
Yeah, yeah, that's what I mean by
iteratively. So,
so we know
that if we integrate over this A
infinity, we get the correct deflection
angle. Well, let's then suppose we just
integrate over the straight
over fiducial light ray which is
undeflected. Right? So, you approximate
A infinity by this region, but of course
there's a mis- there there's a um
you incur
um
a mistake because A infinity actually
contains this region, too. But remember
um the optical metric of course
approaches the Euclidean metric, so even
though this is an infinite region, it
doesn't really contribute much.
So, you get a value for A
with this um
you know, first approximation for the
light ray. Second approximation, you Now
you know there's a there's a so first
order A Let's say A zero,
then you get a better approximation to A
infinity. You plug it in again, get a
new value for A.
This then gives you another correction
and so on.
It's iterative solution.
Now, um you know, this will be A if you
work it out will be an expansion in M.
You can think of this as a Taylor
expansion in M. If you really want to
find the correct value for for A, for
alpha,
you'd have to go through this procedure
of iteratively solving it. Now we just
want to work out the leading order. This
is what I've shown you yesterday. And it
turns out for this it's sufficient to
just approximate A infinity by this
region.
Right?
Well, let's let's see that really this
is the case.
So, now let's work out the leading order
approximation for for alpha, so the one
that's only proportional to M.
And by the way, this um Okay, I'll say
it again.
All right.
Let's say we take this to be our first
approximation for for A infinity.
Now what's the boundary curve?
It's this undeflected light ray.
And what's it given by? Well, R of phi
is what? Uh what?
This is this is R
phi.
Um remember B is a lot bigger than the
Schwarzschild radius. That's what we've
assumed, right? B is a lot bigger than 2
M.
So, we're here already in the Euclidean
region. I can take this to be
B over sin phi.
Right? So, then alpha
will be approximately, well, at first
order anyway, will be the integral of
this
uh Gaussian curvature kappa over
um
A infinity.
I don't remember what the Gaussian
curvature was.
So, recall
kappa for for Schwarzschild
um
we worked it out,
or kind of anyway,
was equal to Oh, yeah.
-2M over R cubed
into 1 - 3M over 2R.
So, we can just do the leading order
calculation.
Um
So, all the R's are a lot bigger than M,
right? By this assumption. So, it's
basically just minus 2M over R cubed.
Um
So, alpha will be approximately
the integral of
-2M over R cubed.
What's uh
What's dA?
Well, of course it will be the square
root of the determinant of G twiddle,
right? Times our coordinates coordinate
area element dr d phi. Guess you've seen
this before.
So, this will just be when the in the
Euclidean region, this will be square
root of R squared
dr d phi, which is basically R dr d phi.
You know this anyway.
So, R dr d phi
integrated from where to where? Well,
from R phi,
which is B over sin phi,
up to infinity.
And then phi
goes from
Oh, it goes to infinity. It goes from
zero to pi.
And that's the that's approximate, of
course, but
at first order.
So, what do we get?
Integral from zero to pi
of um
Well, um of what?
-1 over R squared, that's
-1 over R +1 over R.
Is this right?
So,
d phi.
It's minus, right?
Minus?
Good.
So, this is integral from zero to pi of
2M over B times sin phi d phi.
Well, obviously that's 2M over B.
-cos from zero to pi.
Oh, sorry.
Uh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's right.
But there was a minus in front, right?
Okay.
Huh.
Right?
But there's minus here, I think, and um
that gives us minus minus one, which is
one.
Minus minus
So, that gives us two.
Yes, so it's 4M over B.
Huh.
Right?
Uh or remember, so M was was
physically that's G physical mass over C
squared. So, this is 4GM
over
uh BC squared.
Finally, and that's what I've written
down yesterday. Or what?
What what's the um you know, leading
order deflection angle for light in
general relativity? For Schwarzschild
and then indeed for any any mass if
you're sufficiently far away when it's
compact.
Okay. So, um
Yes, so you can use this method to
compute the deflection angle. I agree
it's maybe not the best way because you
actually have to go through, you know,
you have to go to curvature, you have to
go to second derivative of of a metric.
Um you have to solve it iteratively.
Maybe it's not the best method to to to
use in practice to actually work it out,
but I think conceptually it's
interesting because it really brings out
that lensing is a global effect.
And then in the last Oh.
In the last uh few minutes, sorry I'm
overrunning already.
I just want to discuss or to mention uh
one other example
uh which is not Schwarzschild,
but um
a model for galaxy that astronomers like
to use.
So,
so yeah, I can do that.
What?
Sorry?
Oh, you're still writing.
Can Can I
Can I clean this?
Can you reconstruct what was written
there because I've forgotten?
It's on the video. Oh, okay.
It's in the paper anyway.
Um
So,
This is what Okay.
So, another example
um called the singular isothermal
sphere.
The reason it's called um isothermal is
that it really corresponds to um mass
model where every um massive particle
has the same kinetic temperature and
you're looking for
you know model that's self-consistent
that satisfies process equation
and it's singular because the density
blows up at the center but anyway it's a
this is Newtonian right um
the spatial density as a function of
radius
is is given by this sigma squared over 2
pi g r squared which is the
gravitational constant sigma squared is
the velocity dispersion of the system of
particles
and that's the density so if you like
it's a model for a galaxy I'm afraid
that the density blows up but it doesn't
really matter
too much we can sort of smooth it
and we also you know this is not
Newtonian
the velocity dispersion is a lot less
than the speed of light
it's you know hundreds of kilometers per
second maybe
and um
all of that is in thermodynamic
equilibrium
Indeed yes or if you like a ball of a
ball of point particles massive point
particles so there's a you know a
stellar
kinematics version of this tool which
describes a galaxy if you smooth out um
these massive particles then you get a
spatial density so it's very easy way of
um
thinking about this so it's really if
you like a circularly symmetric galaxy
it's actually not a bad model for galaxy
astronomers like to use it um
now you've got all the machinery in
principle you can work out you know the
the optical geometry let me just tell
you what the result is so you get some
um
you get some optical metric you um
can look at the
at the equatorial plane right total
geodesic you can So that's
so you have this distribution
you make out of this an energy momentum
tensor You could yes
Tolman-Oppenheimer-Volkoff Ah okay You
can do there is a there's a general
relativistic version of this tool it's
by
um
Misner-Novikov But you would need that
You could yes but that's right but then
in the end we're just looking at lensing
in the Newtonian limit and
you know
you you basically plug in
the Newtonian mass distribution again
and from general relativity you just
inherit the factor of two and that's
You need that You need yes Okay Yeah
So all of this can be done special
relativistically with
Tolman-Oppenheimer-Volkoff
but um anyway so this is
what what it looks like Newtonian in in
Newtonian physics setting at large
scales really what we need
The optical geometry of the spatial um
the optical geometry of the equatorial
plane
embedded in r3 so we do exactly the same
as we did before looks like this
So in this limit a bit more complicated
it's square root of 8 sigma squared
times r
So what does that tell you
What does the um
the equatorial plane look like in
optical in optical geometry
It's a cone
right
So um
the mass can be in this in this model It
is yes yes
You can cut it off then um and then the
optical properties depend on whether
you're inside or outside of the cutoff
outside then it would look like
Schwarzschild right inside it would
still look like that
We have a let's let mass diverge it's
sort of a problem for this argument
anyway So um
So we have a
we have a cone in the optical geometry
What does that tell us for the Gaussian
curvature
Zero
Yep
What does that tell us for the
deflection angle
Really
Ah The angle of the cone
The deficit angle yes
So we go through the same argument with
uh Gauss-Bonnet remember the way I've
set it up was really for um
a static specially symmetric spacetime
that approaches Euclidean space um in
the optical geometry at large distance
here well it's flat but it's not quite
Euclidean space actually conic
So you know basically if if you work out
the
the same formula that we did before
kappa will be different
right cuz it's really for conic
spacetime and then alpha will not be
zero so you have to modify this formula
right um it's no longer Euclidean at
large distance and what you get for for
alpha at leading order is 4 pi sigma
squared or it's actually
just half of the deflection of the
deficit angle of a cone so if you you
know you know this picture
you can take a
a disk you can cut out some
oops
some some sector
and then glue these bits together and
then you get a cone right this angle
here is called the deficit angle
and um
of course as far as lensing is concerned
you know on on a cone we have as before
we have geodesics that correspond to
light rays
um and the Gaussian curvature is zero so
they're basically well it
straight light rays except of course we
have this um this conic structure so
light deflection angle not surprisingly
is actually connected to this deficit
angle of the cone it's quite a nice
result
um
so you get a fixed deflection angle if
you have a singular isothermal sphere
and it's translucent right um its
optical properties are such that the
gravitational light deflection angle is
actually independent of distance
and that has to do with this mass
element
if you if you want to work out what's
the mass enclosed within the impact
parameter
you know m
smaller or equal to r Only inside the
distribution Inside will be proportional
to r once it
and then remember the deflection angle
is something like m over r so you can
well if you like enclosed within r
divided by r so you it's not surprising
that that's constant sometimes right of
course you have to do it more precisely
But yes so for the singular isothermal
sphere you get a constant deflection
angle there's another um
now spacetime that you might have met
before um called a cosmic string
Have you seen this in tutorials or
Ah
Okay
Let me just briefly mention it so a
cosmic string
um if you like is a
is a um a
curve that carries mass
in in spacetime
so as you you have a
you know you have a energy momentum
tensor
that um
just has mass along some curve in space
and you ask what's the spacetime where
the solution of Einstein's equation
gives you a conic spacetime
So
as in this case there's a deficit angle
um the deficit angle of course is not in
space but actually in the spacetime but
it's a similar sort of picture you can
work out the light deflection there
and um it's exactly the same
relationship because it's also a cone
the light deflection angle for cosmic
string is half the deflection angle
uh the the def- deficit angle excuse me
of this of this conic spacetime is also
constant
So there's a formal similarity between a
cosmic string and a singular isothermal
sphere two very different models
The the main difference of course is the
following
A cosmic string is a spacetime
the spacetime is what's conic
singular isothermal sphere it's the
spatial part it's the optical geometry
that's conic
What what does that mean
Well if the spacetime is uh for the
cosmic string the spacetime is conic
it has no
it is locally no um no curvature
the curvature is zero so the light rays
are not actually magnified
whereas here
it's just the optical geometry that's
conic the spacetime itself will actually
be curved
so here we have um magnification of of
light rays here we don't
right so for singular isothermal sphere
um
what you see
you might see um
right yeah the light source you might
just see a shifted image but the shifted
image by constant alpha will be brighter
let's say
in the case of the cosmic string you
would have a shifted image but it will
have exactly the same brightness because
it's the spacetime that's conic the
spacetime itself not just the optical
geometry
Anyway one can say a lot more about this
but just give you a flavor
So um
I think that's all I want to say
I've been overrunning anyway so thanks
for your attention
and
Any questions
Yesterday it was mentioned that there
exists
always odd numbers of the images Hm Why
is
Ah
But it would be another lecture um
I'm afraid
I can give you a very quick um argument
for this if you want
You have a light source
uh you have an observer
you have a lens um
let's take the plane through this lens
as a way of characterizing light rays
that go from s to o
Now in in in the standard approximation
of lensing
this is basically Euclidean space
uh you can
formulate it in such a way that you have
Euclidean space but with a plane and at
the plane your light ray your your you
know straight light rays get a kink.
So, they're piecewise straight, really.
Um but anyway, so
for light light starting at S going to
O, um
you can you can characterize all
possible curves, of course, by
specifying where they intersect the lens
plane, right?
Now, all of all these possible curves,
the actual geodesics will have a special
property, as you know. Excuse me. They
will be given by uh Fermat's principle.
So, we have a stationary, of course,
this is now in
standard optics, where
where we're given by by those
curves which have a stationary travel
time.
So, you can plot the travel time, this
is called the Fermat potential phi, as a
function of lens plane coordinates,
let's call this X.
Right? So, let's say the light source is
in another plane called the source
plane.
Um we have some coordinates there called
Y.
Um
I have to write this more more
carefully.
So,
that's the deflection potential uh the
the the Fermat potential, so it depends
on X.
Um
It depends on the source position, but
that's just a fixed parameter.
Right? And then by Fermat's principle,
that's the total travel time. This
corresponds to the geometric time delay,
which just comes from um
the various paths having different
different um paths,
really. Ha. Right? This is a function of
the lens plane coordinate. That's the
rotation time delay.
That's the Shapiro effect, eventually.
And then Fermat's principle says that
where we're looking for stationary
points, so
nabla of phi is equal to zero.
And um
Now, if you plot phi
as a function of of lens plane
coordinate,
you get some graph.
Um
It turns out for a
isolated lens,
all the images which will correspond to
stationary points on the surface
on some finite region.
Um and at large distance,
this uh deflection potential
gravitational deflection potential um
diverges at most logarithmically.
So, it will be
dominated by the polynomial term.
So, at large distance, it will actually
look like a paraboloid.
Right?
So, now counting images comes down to
the simple problem of just counting the
number of critical points on a surface.
Right? The three different types, you
can have minima, maxima, and saddle
points.
Right? So, the total number of images
will the number of minima,
the number of saddle points,
and the number of maxima.
But they're in some finite,
you know, compact region of the surface.
Um out here,
the surface will just look like a like a
paraboloid.
Now, um
there's a theorem
due to Morse,
which says that if you have a closed um
manifold
without boundary of some dimension D,
then um the sum of the critical points,
the regular critical points, of index
lambda
is an alternating sum times minus one to
the lambda
from lambda equals zero up to D is equal
to the Euler characteristic of that
um manifold. What's lambda?
It's an index um it's called the Morse
index.
For for minima,
the Morse index is zero. For saddle
points, it's one, and for maxima, it's
Is that right?
I think it's right. No, sorry, it's the
other way around.
2 1 0. I think.
No, sorry.
It's the other way around. It's 0 1 2.
Anyway,
right?
So, so given this, um
we know the time delay surface which
just look like a paraboloid.
Let's suppose we close the surface
um to actually make a compact manifold
without boundary. Of course, by doing
this, you change the problem in some
sense. Well, anyway, it changes the
problem up here, not down there.
Uh but you introduce an additional
critical point on the top,
a maximum, in fact,
which, of course, does not correspond to
lensed image, right? It's just something
you've introduced.
So, D is equal to two. So, the statement
is the number of minima,
which carries a plus one, minus one to
the zero,
minus the number of saddle points,
right? Minus one to the one, plus the
number of maxima,
minus one to the two, plus sign,
of of lens images, plus the additional
image uh sorry, the additional maximum
at the top, which is not an image, is
equal to chi of a sphere. We've seen
this before in this lecture, equal to
two.
Right?
So, now subtracting these two equations,
magically, you get the total number of
images is twice the number of saddle
points plus one, and that's an odd
number.
But then the plus one can't be the Morse
index for maximum.
Sorry?
If if
two is the Morse index for a maximum,
Mhm.
why do you have to add plus one
on the left hand side?
No, it's the number. It's the number of
critical points of that index.
So, so the number of maxima is the the
number of maxima images down here, plus
an additional maximum which is not an
image.
Yeah.
Isn't it the
uh index plus two one?
No, it's two.
Uh we we discussed this before. For
topological disk, chi is one minus G as
a boundary with holes. For um
for a manifold without boundary like
like a
this, two minus two G.
No hole means G is equal to two.
And indeed, you can check using using
this theorem, right?
Let's have a sphere
and a height function.
Sphere with a height function means you
have two critical points. You have a
south pole and north pole. This will be
what will be the minimum of the height
function. So, it has Morse You have one
minimum
times minus one to the zero is one, plus
um
one maximum, one times one, minus one to
the two,
is equal to chi. Well, obviously, that's
two.
Of course, we have has no boundary.
That's why it's different, right? We
were discussing disks before.
Okay, so you see the total number of
images is actually an odd number, and
that's true as long as
um your mass distribution is finite. In
other words, all the images are in this
compact region.
And um the distri-
Well, you know, this this surface is
smooth.
You can see for Schwarzschild, it
doesn't work.
Uh
it actually has two images, but that's
because
there's a singularity, so it's
deflection potential phi actually looks
like a logarithm. So,
you know, the surface actually looks
like this.
If you see what I mean.
So, um
But anyway, that's that's singular.
That's not really what happens in
nature. In nature, you have a nice
smooth
mass distribution, which is finite, and
that's really what you have. So, you
have an odd number of images. As I as I
said yesterday,
typically, one of the images you can't
see because either you know, the
galaxy's in in front of it, or it's it's
strongly demagnified. So, typically, the
odd number theorem becomes an even
number theorem in uh
in real life.
Hence, for example, the Einstein cross,
right? With the four
images.
Anything? I have a question.
Yes.
If you please,
in your big picture,
the fundamental
geometrical setting, I mean, we've
always been dealing with with a
two-dimensional
Mhm.
setting where we have basically
everything in one plane, and the
Mhm. That's right.
Mhm. That's right. In principle, of
course, you can consider
more lenses
in other positions, other distances.
Then you have a a multi-lens plane
setting.
And um you can actually extend this
argument to that, too.
Um it doesn't quite work like this.
That's a sort of easy easy way out.
You'd have to use um
what's called Morse theory boundary
conditions A and B. They, you know,
it becomes it's a multi-dimensional
version of of of the lens equation.
Uh but but you can still work out um you
can you still use Morse theory to come
up with um
constraints on the image number. Like
this. Yes.
Okay. Lunch?
Okay. Thank you.